philippe béchade bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl france alors la city détrôner c'est
une situation inédite mais est ce que
c'est une surprise finalement dans les
proportions où on observe ce transfert
de chiffre d'affaires oui là il ya quand
même une montée en puissance de rolex
qu'on n'avait pas forcément anticipé
puisque l on était sur la base de sept
milliards et demi des changes quotidien
et sur euronext en comptant toutes les
places ont dépassé un petit peu les 11
milliards
d'un seul coup le 1er janvier le
basculement s'opère et euronext
que gagne un peu plus de 6 milliards et
demi de chiffre d'affaires et londres
qui est a dit qu'ils étaient 17 et demi
milliard d'équivalents euros de chiffre
d'affaires chute à un petit peu plus de
2,9 donc l'autre surprise c'est que
finalement c'est amsterdam qui remporte
la mise
là encore une surprise pourquoi la
bourse d'amsterdam
tout simplement parce que beaucoup
d'intermédiaires aujourd'hui ont leur
siège aux pays bas pour des raisons
fiscale et on a vu surtout les équipes
des grandes banques se déporter
également sur sur amsterdam
voilà et et paris et francfort non fier
non pratiquement enregistré aucune de
progression des volumes
à paris on est toujours en dessous des 4
milliards quotidiens
francfort s'est un peu plus de 5 5
points 5
et bien sûr on aura bientôt filant on
attend ainsi leur dévolu au moins
équivalents à ceux que l'on a à paris
donc peut-être plus euronext va rentrer
dans une dimension qui est passé le cap
des 20 milliards de de chiffre
d'affaires quotidien de très très loin
cette fois ci et pour revenir sur la
france pourquoi le palais brongniart
pourquoi la bourse de paris semble
effrayer les investisseurs finalement à
vous entendre
je pense pas que la bourse de paris est
frais technologiquement tout se passe
bien mais pour des raisons fiscales
il est beaucoup plus avantageux
d'effectuer les transactions aux pays
bas les tarifs sont beaucoup moins
élevés les taxations sont également plus
faibles et surtout on ne craint pas que
les néerlandais met en place des taxes
sur les transactions ce qui pourrait
quand même arrivé à paris et pression
forte pour qu'on mette un petit quelque
chose de pas une taxe tobin les eaux au
minimum un prélèvement marginal sur les
transactions à paris et puis faute et
amsterdam ambitionne en plus de devenir
une très très grande place pour le
négoce des options négociables et voilà
ils ont un savoir-faire la hausse y
compris même qualifié de circulaire
qu'est ce que l'europe elle est là à
gagner dans cette histoire est que la
cce euronext euronext à des concurrents
qui ne sont pas forcément la bourse de
londres
euronext a comme comme concurrent des
plateformes comme turquoise comme bats
et c'est donc on va dire que plus ils
sont gros plus ils vont pouvoir abaisser
les tarifs
et voilà c'est quand on est dans le
monde de la finance c'est quand même
paramètre majeur c'est de pouvoir dire
regardez on est les numéros un et on est
de moins en moins cher et on va faire
des options et vous allez voir il y aura
un volume une profondeur de marché qui
sera optimale est sans équivalent
évidemment ce sont appelés les plates
formes alternatives alors des
discussions sont actuellement en cours
entre londres et bruxelles afin de
régler la question des relations en
matière de services financiers
quelle est la teneur des échanges alors
ça je suis pas trop dans le secret des
dieux
le problème que rencontrent les
britanniques c'est aussi l'accès au
guichet de la bce
la fluidité de la compensation des
opérations transmanche est temps que
cette affaire là des pas réglé je ne
peux pas vous dire quand ni comment les
opérateurs internationaux vont teysseyré
évidemment à ben salah parce que là il
ya aucun problème en étant dans la zone
euro il ya aucun problème
bach et des opérations en euro et de
toute l'ue ring se fait en euros est
donc entre entre londres et l'europe
il ya beaucoup de dossiers qui sont pas
agréés ça fait ça fait presque cinq ans
donc bien malin qui peut dire à quel
point londres va retrouver des
conditions d'opération aussi facile que
c'était le cas avant le break site et en
quelques mots alors est ce que malgré
cinq cycles à city pourra reprendre un
jour sa première place boursière
européenne
alors je réponds non presque d'entrée le
jeu tout simplement parce que l'ensemble
rolex aujourd'hui pèse effectivement
plus lourd et à bourg samsam déjà une
seule pèse lourd que londres et quand
vous allez rajouter l'italie on aura un
ensemble londres de poids pas enfin
pourra pas se comparer en termes de
volume par contre l'ingénierie
financière britannique elle reste
aujourd'hui presque sans rival dans le
monde et vous ne verrez pas tout tous
les family offices tous les fonds
s'ouvre à quitter londres pour aller à
amsterdam et services financiers
proposés par londres reste aujourd'hui
encore une vraie référence mondiale
merci beaucoup philippe béchade de nous
avoir éclairé ce matin dans la matinale
je le rappelle vous êtes rédacteur en
chef de la bourse au quotidien